mais là mesloise et messieurs bonjour 18
morts trois disparus et neuf blessés
c'est le bilan de l'incendié qui hier
soir a ravagé un collège d'enseignement
secondaire rue edouard pailleron à paris
dans le 19ème arrondissement 18 morts et
parmi eux 14 enfants au moins les autres
victimes et disparus sont d'autres
enfants des professeurs et les
concierges de l'établissement un pompier
a été d'autre part grièvement blessé des
poutrelles des blocs de béton un amas de
décombres ce que vous voyez en ce moment
même sur vos images des décombres milieu
desquels les pompiers fouillent thalassa
blement c'est tout ce qui reste ce matin
de cet établissement scolaire dans
lequel hier soir une soixantaine
d'enfants suivait avec quatre
professeurs des cours de musique et de
chant et je pense que ces images parlent
d'elles mêmes une information judiciaire
pour incendie vol involontaire est
ouverte dès ce matin une commission
denquête s'est rendu sur place
les enquêteurs vont entendre les
pompiers les témoins les sauveteurs
volontaires les rescapés comme toujours
en pareil cas et comme toujours en
pareil cas on se pose des questions on
cherche des responsables on reste
abasourdi effondré devant un pareil
drame dont des enfants sont les inox les
innocentes victimes et l'on songe que
quelques heures plus tôt ce n'est pas 60
mhz et 900 enfants qu'il y avait dans ce
crs on songe avant tout à la douleur des
parents
voyons tout d'abord ce qui s'est passé
comment ce qui n'était qu'un incendie
important certes mais comme il y en a
tous les jours en france est devenue
hier soir à paris une tragédie jacques
collet 20 heures rue edouard pailleron
19e arrondissement un crs une
construction récente à peine trois ans
mais de matériaux légers à l'intérieur
fait inhabituel à cette heure-là 50
adolescents prennent une leçon de soul
fèves avait que trois professeurs
et dans les couloirs la concierge de
l'établissement on attend également pour
une séance de ciné club
soudain le feu pourquoi comment on ne
sait toujours pas seulement là haut dans
les étages on ne s'aperçoit pas de ce
qui arrive tout de suite les enfants et
les enseignants veulent fuir mais la
fumée âcre et épaisse barre la route de
l'escalier les fenêtres tout hélas ne
s'ouvre pas et c'est à coups de poing
que le professeur de solfège casse les
carreaux libérant ainsi un grand nombre
de ces élèves qui descendent alors le
nom de la façade
les chiens des secouristes étant déjà
dressé les pompiers luttent nombreux
huit casernes en tout pendant deux
heures cet incendie ne sera qu'un feu
banal un crs et ravagé certes mais il ne
semble pas qu'il y ait de victime
et pourtant à 22h15 camp le lieutenant
vigier vient dresser le bilan personne
ne s'attend à l'annoncé d'un tel drame
c'est que vous annoncez à l'instant
présent c'est comme malheureusement nous
venons de découvrir une quinzaine de
victimes
ce sont des enfants
et étant donné l'état des corps et la
situation dans laquelle j'ai dû les voir
moi-même
on peut croire qu'ils étaient à gagner
est assez peu au dessus des décombres de
la partie fondé du wali à cette
consternation succès de l'affolement
les parents ne savent rien ou et leurs
enfants at il été conduit dans un
hôpital peut-être mais lequel
ou alors est il là dedans la tragédie
s'installe sur deux centres d'intérêts
l'héroïne du collège où l'on dégage les
corps d'un côté et la mairie du 19e de
l'autre où les parents affolés et c'est
de savoir demande des listes
cet immense détresse le général des
pompiers la ressent lui même je pense
initialement qu'il est une victime
jusqu'à nous avaient dit qu'un enfant
n'était pas sceptique ce cas la plume
plus d'un je suis navré mais les
pompiers ont fait leurs devoirs tout
leur métier avec beaucoup de courage
d'ailleurs d'après les premiers témoins
vous l'avez entendu tout s'est passé
très vite en quelques minutes monsieur
jolivet est l'un des professeurs de
musique qui était dans ce crs et qui est
sans doute le seul survivant des quatre
professeurs présents a déclaré je ne me
suis aperçu de rien pas d'explosion pas
d'odeur pas de flammes des enfants sont
arrivées dans ma classe ils m'ont dit
monsieur il y a le feu
j'avais treize élèves avec moi tous très
jeunes quand nous sommes arrivés dans
l'escalier il était déjà impraticable à
cause de la fumée
alors nous sommes rentrés dans la classe
nous avons passé nous avons cassé les
fenêtres
nous avons crié et nous sommes descendus
un par un par des échelles en bas dans
la rue je me suis aperçu qu'il me
manquait deux enfants
je voulais dit dès ce matin une
commission denquête s'est rendu sur
place pour essayer de connaître les
causes de cette catastrophe
on avait parlé d'une fuite de gaz or la
direction du gaz de france précise qu'il
n'y avait aucune installation de gaz
dans les étages et que la conduite qui
alimente l immeuble a été retrouvé
intact pour les pompiers il n'y a à
première vue aucune explication possible
vous venez d'entendre le général fait
rouge qui les commande il a dit les
responsabilités s'il y en a elles ne
sont pas notre fait
quand nous sommes arrivés il était déjà
trop tard le maire du 19e arrondissement
monsieur petit à
rappelé qu'une commission de sécurité
avait visité plusieurs fois
d'établissement depuis son ouverture il
ya deux ans et n'avait rien noté
d'anormal
en ce qui concerne le bâtiment lui même
cependant monsieur petit a reconnu que
des fissures s'était produite il ya
plusieurs mois dans la cour de ce crs
alors n'est ce pas ne sont ce pas les
matériaux employés pour la construction
de cet établissement scolaire qui
pourrait peut-être incriminés parce
qu'il s'agit d'un établissement scolaire
monsieur fontanet le ministre de
l'éducation nationale s'est rendu sur
place dans la nuit et dès ce matin il a
réuni dans son bureau
tous les responsables de la construction
dans son ministère
voici ce qu'il a déclaré à dominique
laurie je lis parce que vous avez des
éléments nouveaux ce matin non comme
vous le savez dès cette nuit je me suis
rendu sur les lieux de cet épouvantable
si nice mais je n'ai pu recueillir que
des impressions d'où il ressort que le
feu s'est propagé avec une rapidité
extraordinaire ce qui explique hélas le
nombre des victimes
il faut donc avoir l'explication de ce
phénomène pour le moment extrêmement
surprenants
une enquête judiciaire a immédiatement
été commencées et puisque hélas il ya eu
des morts et dès ce matin nous lançons
l'enquêté administrative
ces résultats seront rendus publics et
nous tirons bien entendu toutes les
conséquences qui s'imposeront à partir
du moment où nous aurons l'explication
de ce drame épouvantable
je me dis c'est quand même des points
d'interrogation le s'est écroulé comme
un véritable château de cartes il faut
sur tous ces points comme je viens de le
dire la rapidité avec laquelle le feu
s'est propagé les conséquences que cela
a causés sur le plan de la solidité de
l'immeuble que les explications
techniques soient fournis je ne peux
rien vous dire de plus pour le moment
mais tous ces points vont être examinés
avec la plus grande rapidité le plus
grand soin pour que rien ne reste dans
l'ombre
et encore une fois ces conclusions
seront rendues publiques voilà tout ce
que l'on peut dire sur ce drame d'après
ce que l'on sait actuellement il faut
maintenant d'attendre les résultats de
l'enquêté résultats dont monsieur
fontanet a promis qu'il serait rendue
publique
une réunion se tiendra cet après midi
entre les parents des élèves de 6es et
le rectorat de paris afin d'organiser
la répartition des enfants dans
différentes dans différents
établissements du secteur
d'autre part une réunion d'information
de pour les parents aura lieu ce soir à
20h45 au lycée bergson et je pense qu'en
attendant l'enquète parce que au fond
nous sommes tous des parents le mieux
c'est de la voir une pensée pour les
victimes d'hier soir 47 36 14 et 3 ce
sont les pourcentages d'intentions de
vote des français obtenu par le dernier
sondage de la sofres et que publie ce
matin le figaro
47 c'est le pourcentage obtenu par
l'opposition de gauche et qui se
décompose de la façon suivante 25 % pour
le parti socialiste les radicaux de
gauche et le ps eu 22 % pour le parti
communiste
par rapport au précédent sondage l'union
de la gauche gagne donc un point 36%
c'est le pourcentage obtenu par la
majorité
ces deux points de moins qu'aux
précédents sondages quant aux
réformateurs
il reste à 14% enfin 3% ce sont les
divers droite qui gagnent un point
autre résultat intéressant à noter dans
ce sondage à la veille de l'intervention
télévisée de monsieur pompidou 58% des
personnes interrogées estiment que le
président de la république est un
arbitre au dessus des partis
34% estiment qui est le chef de la
majorité 8% n'ont pas d'opinion
hier soir au palais des sports de paris
le parti communiste avait organisé un
meeting sur le thème voter massivement
pour les candidats du pcc donner la
meilleure chance au programme commun de
la gauche
on répète sans cesse qu'il faut
équilibrer la gauche là encore il faut
parler clair si l'on est objectif il
faut reconnaît qu'effectivement la
gauche au parlement n'est pas équilibré
mais que ce déséquilibre est au
détriment des communistes il faut que
notre parti augmente considérablement
son nombre de voix dès le premier tour
du scrutin
car c'est au premier tour que les choses
se décident au deuxième tour il sera
trop tard
et pour changer vraiment pourquoi
gouvernement pour qu au gouvernement la
voix des travailleurs se fasse entente
avec assez de force
il faut un gouvernement avec les
communistes
oui la france a besoin d'un autre
gouvernement
elle a besoin d'un gouvernement de la
gauche unie dans lequel les communistes
occuperont des postes responsable et un
wagon avec leurs représentants des
autres partis à la réalisation du
programme commun devenu celui de la
majorité des français
un caennais où il était venu soutenir la
candidature de monsieur jean louis debré
le fils du ministre de la défense
monsieur pierre messmer a indirectement
répondu à monsieur marchait en évoquant
ce qui se passerait selon lui si les
communistes et leurs alliés arrivait au
pouvoir
je leur dis que les changements qu'il
souhaite
nous les voulons aussi car ils sont
l'expression même des progrès de la vie
en société
je leur dis qu'avec l'immense majorité
d'entre nous refusons la révolution mais
je leur dis que s'ils triomphent l
alliance que les chefs socialistes ont
conclu avec le parti communiste
aucune force quelle que soit
l'importance de sa représentation
parlementaire ne pourrait équilibrer le
parti communiste
quand les communistes et leurs alliés
sont au pouvoir
ce ne sont pas leurs alliés qui gouverne
ce sont les communistes eux-mêmes car
quoi qu'on dise et quoi qu'on fasse le
seul en ont les moyens seul dispose des
masses de manoeuvre qui leur permettent
d'occuper les usines ou d'occuper la rue
seule commande ses moyens de
transmission que sont certaines
associations ou la puissante
organisation syndicale qu'il contrôle au
sol dès lors peuvent ralentir ou
accélérer les mouvements et par la
pression qu'ils exercent arracher les
décisions que veut obtenir le parti
communiste et on le sait bien à calais
où le parti communiste a bloqué la mise
en place d'un schéma d'aménagement qui
est un outil pour l'avenir à marseille
monsieur jean lecanuet qui présidait
avec monsieur servan-schreiber un
meeting des réformateurs a rappelé
quelle sera la position des réformateurs
au lendemain des élections du mois de
mars à la veille d'importantes
déclarations de monsieur le président de
la république je tiens à clarifier notre
position nous serons je crois
indispensable à une majorité nouvelle
mais en aucun cas nous n'apportons nos
voix gratuitement pour combler les vides
de la majorité et faire la politique que
nous avons combattu
nous n'apporterons notre concours qu'à
une politique de réformes qui donnera
comme directive au prochain gouvernement
les principales réformes que j'ai
rappelé tout à l'heure
enfin à périgueux monsieur alain poher
le président du sénat s'est défendu de
vouloir faire campagne pour telle ou
telle formation politique
au matin du 12 mars at il dit je
souhaite rester un arbitre national 200
membres de l'association nationale pour
l'étude de l'avortement ont à leur tour
pris position leurs représentants ont
expliqué ce matin au cours d'une
conférence de presse
dans quels cas précis il admettait
l'avortement
aujourd'hui nouveau rebondissement de la
bataille de l'avortement 206 médecins et
non des moindres puisqu'on compte par
lieu les quatre prix nobel est un
certain nombre de professeurs de faculté
ont déclaré qu'ils avaient facilité ou
réaliser des avortements depuis le
printemps 2009 172
mais dans quelles conditions et pour
quelle raison exactement dr palmer en
fait il s'est constitué au sein de
l'année à un groupe qui a signé une
charte dans laquelle il s'engageait à
réaliser en france des interruptions de
grossesse dans les conditions suivantes
menace grave pour la santé de la femme
risque sérieux d'enfants malformés
maladies mentales graves de la mer viol
ou d'inceste mineur de moins de 15 ans
et indications social d'une gravité
indiscutable en d'autres termes votre
avortement est justifiée dans tous ces
cas là semble-t-il sont tous des cas
dans lesquels jorion estimé être
coupable de ne pas avoir réalisé
l'interruption de la grossesse en notre
âme et conscience
mais cette position à la fois morale et
médical s'oppose-t-elle alors à
l'avortement libre à répétition tel que
le demande les 333
évidemment nous ne couvrons pas tout
l'éventail des cas qui recourt à
l'avortement clandestin
je pense personnellement qu avec la
manière nous avons envisagé les choses
nous évitons plus de la moitié de ceux
ci il est certain que des indications
sont restrictives par rapport à celles
de nos collègues des 330 dont nous
sommes cependant pleinement solidaire
je vous rappelle que hier monsieur jean
foyer le ministre de la santé publique a
estimé que le manifeste des 330 médecin
était une manoeuvre de provocation et
une opération politique déclenché en
pleine période électorale
la guerre a décidément bien du mal à
cesser au vietnam sur les hauts plateaux
dans la région de plaies coup une
bataille rangée entre soldats geth kong
et sud vietnamien a fait près de 200
morts dans la seule journée d'hier
d'autre part dans la région de huer les
sud-vietnamien affirme avoir détruit
sept chars nord-vietnamiens qui
tentaient de s'emparer d'une de leurs
positions dans cette même région une
équipe de onze délégués de la commission
de contrôle n'a pu mettre fin à un duel
d'artillerie
elle a dû rentrer à hué pour se
contenter de faire un rapport cependant
à paris les délégués de saigon et du grp
se sont retrouvés pour la deuxième fois
ce matin dans une atmosphère qualifiée
de part et d'autre de constructif
d'après un journal de beyrouth trois
membres de l'organisation palestinienne
septembre noir avaient projeté de
somparé à vienne d'un wagon qui
transportait des juifs soviétiques qui
venait de quitter leur pays
mais toujours d'après ce journal les
services de renseignement soviétiques
ont eu vent de cette affaire et ils ont
alerté la police autrichienne qui a pu
arrêter les trois palestiniens
les lecteurs de georges simenon vont
être déçus le célèbre romancier a décidé
de ne plus écrire dans une interview que
publie ce matin le journal de lausanne
24 heures le père du commissaire maigret
affirme j'ai pris la décision de ne plus
écrire de romans désormais sur mon
passeport je suis sans profession
simenon déclare qu'il veut désormais
rester assis dans un fauteuil et se
raconter des histoires qu'il oubliera
aussi tôt les basketteurs de donna ont
battu hier soir l'équipe de barcelone
par 73 points à 61 en coupes européennes
korac
ils ont donc 12 points d'avance pour le
match retour qui aura lieu à barcelone
la semaine prochaine quelques images de
cette rencontre pour les joueurs de
données en maillot sombre qui affrontait
dans leur salle l'équipe de barcelone
l'objectif était non seulement de gagner
mais surtout d'assurer une marge de
poing suffisante pour conserver une
chance lors du match retour en espagne
il y avait les deux américains de
services dans chaque formation et le
duel au rebond que ce livre est celui de
denain sanders de mettre 12 avec celui
de barcelone car michael de m 09
conditionner la partie à la mi temps
vous l'avez vu le score de 33 à 32 en
faveur des français ne pouvait laisser
présager de la suite de pang barcelone
menait 53,50 quelques minutes plus tard
grâce à l'activité de il est hélas
denain parvenait à reprendre l'avantagé
concrétisée par six points d'écart à
trois minutes de la fin
pendant ce laps de temps toujours
décisif dans une partie de basket
les espagnols devaient perdre solaire
leur tireur le plus adroit éliminé pour
cinq fautes personnelles
mettant cette aubaine à profit les
denaisiens survolté parviendront à
porter la marque à 73 61 12 points
d'écart c'est un avantage qui laisse
quelques chances à denain mais aussi aux
espagnols un coup dur pour l'équipe de
france de rugby trio ne jouera pas
samedi contre les all blacks ce trio a
été blessée à la tête dimanche dernier
et pour le remplacer les sélectionneurs
prendrons une décision aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui également à clermont ferrand
les all-blacks rencontre une sélection
française avant le test match de samedi
comme avant-hier la partie magazine de
ce journal est consacrée au livre
politique particulièrement nombreux en
cette période électorale
maurice bruzac vous présente
quelques-uns des livre récemment sorti
en librairie
la bibliothèque de l'électeur numéro 2
de service politique de 24 heures sur la
une a sélectionné encore pour vous
quelques livres politiques qui vous
permettront de mieux comprendre et de
mieux suivre la campagne électorale le
premier de six titres les paradis
viennent un livre qui a été écrit par
brigitte gros brigitte gros est une
ancienne journaliste est actuellement
maire de meulan une commune importante
de la banlieue ouest de paris
ce livre permet de mieux comprendre
quelles sont actuellement les
préoccupations des élus locaux
ce qui est intéressant donc à la veille
de la consultation voici le titre
les paras 10e par brigitte gros elle est
interviewée par jacqueline moline les
paradis viennent ce sont les habitants
du grand ensemble de meulan à une
cinquantaine de kilomètres de paris
la firme qui était là il y encore
quelques années ça plaît le paradis il y
avait quand nous sommes arrivés à un mec
me l'an 600 demandes de logements
sociaux c'est à dire pour les familles
qui ont un salaire relativement modeste
fallait que ces jeunes ménages en fête
puisse rester à meulan là où ils avaient
passé leur enfance près de leurs parents
ce qui fait que notre devoir le plus
strict et des de construire un groupe de
celle m
pour répondre à cette demande de
logements et c'est pas tout à fait le
paradis
vraiment mais il ya non c'est pas tout à
fait le paradis c'est à dire que
l'endroit est exceptionnellement beau
c'est en haut de la colline qui domine
deux vallées mais le problème c'est
surtout un problème pour les femmes car
voyez-vous ici les hommes sont très
heureux c'est un peu la ville et la
campagne
les femmes s'ennuie les sommes non parce
que évidemment ils partent le matin ils
rentrent tard le soir ils sont
accueillis par une femme dans un très
beau logement qui sont contents c'est
bien aussi pour les enfants je les dis
dans mon livre car nous avons une très
belle école les enfants des espaces
verts
mais le problème c'est la femme les
premières victimes ce sont des femmes
depuis que j'ai créé mon lit nous avons
une pharmacie juste en dessous mais ça
n'est pas suffisant une pharmacie ce
n'est pas suffisant simplement une
grande épicerie
ce n'est pas suffisant une seule
libraires elle voudrait aussi un
coiffeur elle voudrait aussi
une pâtisserie c'est très important un
café c'est ce qu'a fait long j'ai parlé
dans mon livre les femmes aimeraient se
retrouver l'après midi mais où il y
avait un endroit
oui elle s'ennuie parce qu'il n'ya pas
de travail dans le groupe même et quand
elles veulent travailler pour qu'ils
aillent très loin alors quand melzer des
enfants jeunes elles veulent travailler
près de leur logement le grand problème
c'est la distance emploi un logement
quand on construit des cités nouvelles
comme celle ci il faudrait en fait des
bureaux pour qu'elle puisse travailler
comme secrétaire comme employée de
bureau
et puis qu'elle puisse rentrer tôt le
soir chez elle c'est ça le grand
problème quand on a des enfants jeunes
et bien peut pas être absent douze
heures du foyer quand vous aviez fait
les premiers projets si vous n'aviez pas
prévu
toutes ces sommes tous ces inconnus ou
miss hélary la ville dont j'ai rêvé
nous avions prévu tout ça mais il ya un
manque de crédits il ya un manque de
possibilité de réaliser les équipements
en même temps que les logements les
choses viennent mais toujours avec 20
ans de retard et 20 ans et la vie d'une
part à 10 yens la vie d'une part à 10
yens active en facilitateur sein est ce
que vous feriez ce que vous avez fait
ici au oui je ne regrette rien parce
qu'en fait j'ai donné à ces gens qui le
demandaient des logements sociaux de
grande qualité
alors c'est pas la perfection ce n'est
pas encore le paradis mais je lui pour
que ça le devienne
hamelin et ailleurs d'ailleurs anciens
gaulliste passé chez les réformateurs
jean marcel jeanneney vient d'écrire un
livre dont le titre résume sa pensée à
mes amis gaullistes ils justifient donc
en grande partie son passage des
gaullistes chez les réformateurs voici
ce livre voici son titre jean marcel
jeanneney à mes amis gaullistes autre
livre un livre écrit par un gaulliste
parmi les grand gaulliste hollis parmi
les grand gaulliste michel debré combat
pour les élections 1973 c'est un livre
qui s'adresse aux militants
michel debré a repris dans son ouvrage
cinq discours qu'il a prononcé au cours
de ces dernières années mais je vous
propose d'écouter ce qu'il a précisé
dans son interview accordée à jacques
hébert ce livre comprend
cinq discours que j'ai prononcé au cours
des derniers mois devant des militants
c'est à dire les militants qui au cours
des dernières années s'était dévoué pour
la cause pour la personne du général de
gaulle et raison prince la raison
principale de mon propos était de leur
expliquer qu'il fallait se tourner vers
l'avenir que le passé que nous avions
vécu ensemble avec toutes ses promesses
et toutes ces réalisations ne pouvait
être qu'une base de départ en fait la
mort du général de gaulle divise un
certain nombre d'esprits en deux là qui
dit l'après gaullisme c'est le contraire
du gaullisme et l'autre l'après
gaullisme c'est d'essayer de continuer
sur des lignes essentielles et tournée
vers l'avenir
en aucune façon vers le passé ne
craignez vous pas qu'on puisse vous
reprocher un jour de vouloir accaparer
en quelque sorte la mémoire du général
de gaulle en aucune façon je ne cesse de
dire et je n'ai cessé de dire dans ses
discours que le fait de vouloir être
fidèle à certaines orientations un
certain état d'esprit ne justifiait
coulaud une façon une volonté de
monopole bien au contraire
dans votre livre vous parlez souvent des
militants qui dit vous mérite
considération pour vous lourd en 1973
est il toujours nécessaire qu'un parti
politique et des militants des militants
qui en première ligne une démocratie ne
peut pas vivre sans formation politique
parti mouvement rassemblement et c'est
parti ses mouvements et ses
rassemblements n'ont de valeur que s'ils
ont des militants et c'est à dire des
hommes des femmes qui n'ont pas
d'ambitions en ce qui concerne les
mandats en ce qui concerne les élections
mais qui n'ont pas non plus le goût de
s'intéresser à la politique comme au
mans les élections il faut
yves pour une certain idéal il faut
animer une certaine orientation
politique
c'est cela l'état d'esprit du militant
il est hautement respectable en soi et
il est hautement respectable en ce sens
que 100 militants il n'y a pas de
république
comment mieux formuler son choix à
quelques semaines des élections
comment se renseigner auprès des partis
politiques ce sont deux des questions
que l'on se pose très souvent à la
veille d'une consultation électorale et
biya deux livres qui peuvent peut-être
vous aider à répondre en partie ou en
grande partie à ces questions de livres
qui sont des guides le premier si vous
voulez voter et si vous voulez savoir
voter voici sa couverture sur lui vous
permet non seulement de trouver le nom
des responsables des partis mais aussi
l'adresse de ses parties est de trouver
un résumé des programmes politiques de
ses parts
un guide peut être un peu plus complet
le guide des élections par daniel duigou
se livrent également vous permet de vous
y retrouver et de contacter par
téléphone ou par écrit les partis
politiques
dernier ouvrage que nous souhaitons vous
présenter aujourd'hui un livre qui a été
écrit par michel rocard
le titre est question à l'état
socialiste à jan kozak michel rocard
précise qu'elle est son socialisme à lui
une vingtaine de pays dans le monde
prétendent peu ou prou au socialisme et
vous êtes assez sévère à leur égard
vous ne les prenez pas pour modèle c'est
pas une question de sévérité
en effet les pays qui se recommandent du
socialisme fournissent une référence qui
je prends ne convient de voir la france
tous étaient des pays très pauvres au
démarrage tous sont arrivés au
socialisme sans avoir derrière eux une
tradition de démocratie une tradition
d'exercice de liberté collective liberté
politique exclusivement bien sûr dans
l'économie
pour question toute façon et tous aussi
sont arrivés au socialisme
avec une population largement
analphabète il en est résulté des
structures extrêmement centralisé
bureaucratique et parfois policière je
fais pas de jugement de valeur dans ce
livre je suis en effet très critique
mais surtout pour expliquer que les
problèmes françaises n'ont rien à voir
avec le type de socialisme sur lequel
nous pouvons nous battre pour lequel
nous pouvons nous battre ne prendra pas
ses modèles là vous êtes également
sévères critiques à l'égard des ondes la
social démocratie en général et bien
comment ne pas l'être
elle existe depuis plus d'un siècle
maintenant et dans tous les pays
développés elle n'a jamais entrepris
vraiment la construction d'une société
socialiste de la social démocratie s'est
battus parfois mal comme en france et en
angleterre parfois plus efficacement
comme en suède pour un partage plus
juste des revenus nationale mais ce que
nous ce dont nous sommes douze personnes
et aujourd'hui c'est que la question
centrale c'est nous ne voulons plus
vivre comme des sujets de ne voulons
plus passer notre vie obéir à des
décisions prises ailleurs au dessus sans
même qu'on sache qu'il est prend ce
combat là qui est improbable pour la
responsabilité que chacun puisse choisir
ceux qui décident non pas seulement le
président de la république
mais toutes les décisions dont effet
notre avenir immédiat cette décision-là
la social démocratie ne la pose pas si
la raison pour laquelle partout en
europe se cherche des forces qui veulent
la pause et nous espérons avoir pu vous
aider à constituer ce que nous appelons
la bibliothèque de l'électeur après
demain vendredi nous vous présenterons
une troisième émission que nous avons
intitulé la bibliothèque de l'électeur
numéro trois au cours de cette émission
de vous présenteront d'autres ouvrages
après demain vendredi
le cours du dollar est retombé ce matin
à son niveau plancher à la bourse de
francfort mais il s'est un peu redressé
à zurich et aussi à paris en fait michel
tardieu on attend maintenant surtout les
décisions que pour répondre cet après
midi à bonn la banque que fédéral michel
tardieu 14 heures le conseil de la boj
banque se réunit à 14 heures et il est
évident que avant de connaître décision
que peuvent prendre les autorités
monétaires allemande on ne peut faire
que les suppositions et je veux dire que
les suppositions vont bon train ici à la
bourse de paris on en entend de toutes
les couleurs sur le ce que vont faire
les allemands alors on ne peut encore
rien dire il faut attendre je répète
quelques temps les indices double marché
va faire des progrès en allemagne encore
que beaucoup d'allemands dit ce n'est
pas possible de faire un double marché
chez nous parce que nous n'avons pas les
contrôles nécessaires d'eau disent que
d'ores et déjà à bout nous manque ce qui
est en train d'arrêter soutenir le
dollar en ce moment ce qui ferait que le
marque commencerait à flotter en fait
mais je répète aucune information
sérieuse pour l'instant donc il est plus
sage d'attendre puisque dans ce domaine
tous tout est très très fragile
les boursiers en tout cas sont inquiets
et l'or continue de monter leur monde
pour les raisons monétaires que nous
venons de voir et vous voyez que le
lingot à 11 1366 contre 11 1985 hier les
pièces elles moins bouger à l'exception
du full vin qui est en hausse à 130
contre 125 10 on dit sur le marché nord
comme ce que nombre de gens commencent à
arbitrer des pièces contre du kilo vous
savez c'est le jeu habituel des
professionnels de l'or quand la prime
est suffisante sur les pièces ont raison
des pièces et puis on rachète du kilo en
tout cas on ne cesse de battre des
records sur le marché de l'or en raison
précisément donc de la faiblesse du
dollar plus le dollar est faible plus
leur est solide et aussi parce que
nouveau sondage électoral aujourd'hui
est que les boursiers évidemment
commence à être un petit peu fatigués
ils ont les nerfs un petit peu usé par
ces sondages successifs et à chaque
nouveau sondage est bien la bourse
s'effrite un petit peu quand on voit que
la gauche que l'union de la gauche
marque des points vous voyez que
l'effritement l'emportent nettement
aujourd'hui sur l'ensemble des
compartiments boursiers
les bosses sont d'autant plus inquiets
que l'affrontement entre l'europe et les
états unis leur semble devoir être de
plus en plus dur est qu'à sa trempe de
conseillers économiques du président
nixon et notamment leur chef ne
suscitait ont déclaré que les états unis
pourraient bien prendre des mesures
unilatérales pour rééquilibrer leur
balance commerciale
en clair cela veut dire que les états
unis pourraient si il ne tenait pas des
satisfactions de la part des européens
prendre de nouvelles mesures pour taxer
par exemple les importations comme il
l'avait fait au mois d'août 1971 alors
tout ça n'est pas très réjouissant une
seule chose qui pourrait faire plaisir
aux européens c'est que monsieur john
connolly l'ancien secrétaire au trésor
américain qui était bien connu pour sa
brutalité dans les réunions
internationales et ça vous habitez à
l'égard de l'europe notamment vient
d'être nommé administrateur de la panam
la panam qui a récemment refusé de lever
ses options sur le concorde et peut-être
que si monsieur connelly fait une
carrière dans le privé et bien les
négociateurs européens ne le
rencontreront plus pendant les
négociations qui vont s'engager entre
l'europe et les états unis
un signaler que international ni que
inco idée raciale ni qu'elle a fait
connaître ses projets pour
l'exploitation du nickel de nouvelle
calédonie mais que le problème n'est
toujours pas tranchée
c'est qu'au gouvernement de décider
s'ils préfèrent international nickel ou
le groupe formé entre freeport et les
pétroles d'aquitaine
quand opinait ils baissent en tout et
aujourd'hui il est à 211 20 contre 213
le napoléon lui ne vous l'avez vu ne
bougeait pas ici la bourse de paris
avoue claude guillaumin il me reste à
vous remercier de nous avoir prêté
attention et à vous souhaiter un bon
après midi